Tony Rob we got quite the package here
this is oh shoot ah Batman vs Superman
dawn of justice but more importantly
from general mills meaning cereal slowly
open this puppy up Batman cereal what
kind it's hot chocolate strawberry
cereal what that describes Batman yeah
you know dark on the outside fruity and
the inside because it made it goes back
to the do you bleed oh but he said that
Superman's maybes like I bleed I believe
strawberries huh that's a sure that's
good point there and then Superman
caramel crunch cereal good lord yeah
what I'm curious cuz these these are
kind of fancy boxes right I doubt
they're gonna do that in the stores now
I can spend the money on that now maybe
these are like bloomin addition there's
more there is this crazy box it was sent
to us okay so you know if you really
want to get into it you can wear
Superman's cape this is huge Cape is
heavy
good lord this is a legit k well which
one do you want to eat we also have
aware of these and eat the cereal eyes
that's gonna happen we have an
inaccurate Batman mask oh these are way
too long oh man already wait you can't
put code artists like it doesn't corner
well I get both chocolate and I get both
strawberry smell it's it's in here I can
set and tell her she's pretty much no i
don't know what i want to eat you know I
actually had cereal this morning it's
just Cheerios bad plan Cheerios I'd
cereal last night I had a Christmas or
holiday themed captain crunch oh well
this is gonna be a little different all
right now when you eat the cereal you
start eating right away I try to fluff
it up a little bit yeah get it soaking
up some of the milk yeah now we should
point out I don't know if you can see
the Superman cereal maybe you can see it
better in the Box are supposed to be in
the shape of the Superman emblem yeah it
looks like it and here with some classic
bats classic all right is this gonna
block my mask no
that is caramel but how much space is
yours have I'm tasting just a hint the
caramel I took it's a little it's a
little fifty-fifty here I think more
chocolate maybe then uh strawberry the
smell was definitely strawberry huh
reminds me a lot sirmione a warm summer
day no not Batman a cold dark night in
the alley when your parents were killed
Oh dad just reminds me of a planet
exploding mmm but sweeter love it well
that goes for this unboxing video
Lincoln sec your grocery stores if they
have this yeah movie it's in theaters
March 22 fifth that's right and for all
of your unboxing gimmicks and fun stuff
you go to gamespot com
you